Channing Tatum never got some acting
talent who does not think that when they
hear the title of this movie seriously
the eagle is a really hard movie to
critique because it's like two movies in
one so long story short Channing Tatum's
dad screwed up and lost the golden eagle
of Rome so now to get his family on her
back he needs to go get it this happens
after a long as useless back story in
which he gets wounded in war and
whatever so he takes his man slave
played by the other jumper and they
embark on their boring journey I say
boring journey because it's like all the
long slow parts of like an MMO like you
know when you're playing an MMO and you
usually soloing this some random guys
like hey you want to do quest with me
and you're like okay yes sure and you
end up walking around doing nothing
you're like who is this jackass a lot
like how the eagle is they just walk and
walk it's like the long boring slow
parts of The Lord of the Rings book with
no pay off with cool characters and most
of the movie deals with this perception
is reality kind of thing which is true
and it is a good point
Channing Tatum is supposed to be a
badass Roman soldier then there's this
slave from Britain so it's like oh you
guys are douches and I'm cool and this
is why and you're like yeah he has a
point and then it's like oh no I'm cool
and you guys are douches and this is why
you're like yeah okay he has a point but
it does this back and forth this I walk
in your shoes you walk in mind you see
how it is who life is hard and your
shoes kind of thing it just feels like
it's really shoved down your throat even
though it is a good point but at that
point it's all about execution I mean I
can tell someone okay how about this
here's a superhero movie in which
someone doesn't have their sight and
they need to rely on their other senses
and they can hear things really well and
almost have like a radar sense but the
cool thing is the guy's blinding kicks
ass yeah okay cool yeah down with that
sweet here's daredevil a concepts like
10% of what makes a movie cool there are
a lot of other things involved
Channing Tatum for instance not a good
actor I'm pretty sure this is the
Channing Tatum story he was Channing
Tatum he did GI Joe no one liked him so
he changes his name to Sam Worthington
does avatar people like him now does
Clash of the Titans no one likes him any
more than he goes back to being Channing
Tatum pretty sure that's a fact and you
could say yeah the movies not boring
it's character based so when you make a
character based movie based on a stupid
character played by a bad actor not
smart not smart at all then after about
an hour and 15 minutes to an hour and a
half the movie picks up and then they
have to get away from this like fleet of
guys that are coming after him they just
have to outrun him and that
cool I was like okay you have a clear
enemy on your trail you have to outrun
them awesome there's even a cool
throwdown I'm not saying that's the deep
part of a movie I'm just saying at that
point that was the cool part of the
movie so bad acting stupid characters in
a slow movie I would have said [ __ ]
but the last half-hour of this movie
saved it from that
so the first 3/4 of the movie [ __ ]
last quarter of the movie is okay but
you're not gonna remember it in t-minus
13 minutes that's why I had to just do
this review right now because as of
tomorrow I'm not gonna remember this
movie at all by the time you watch this
review I will not even remember the
movie but if you like what you've seen
here and you want to see more click
right here to see more